y se ha hecho muy poco para solucionarlo.
Si fueran magos y pensaran que la energía nuclear limpia, abundante
y libre de carbón es la clave para luchar contra el cambio climático,
tienen que preocuparse
de que el apoyo de la gente a construir armas nucleares disminuya.
Si son profetas y piensan que la solución al mismo problema
son esas instalaciones solares de barrio que llevan energía de un lado a otro,
tendrán que preocuparse de que ninguna nación en el mundo
dedique ningún recurso al desarrollo de esa tecnología
ni la use cuando la necesitamos.
Y si están en cualquiera de los bandos, magos o profetas,
deben preocuparse de que, a pesar de la gran alarma sobre el cambio climático,
la cantidad de energía generada cada año por combustibles fósiles
ha aumentado un 30 % desde el inicio de este siglo.
¿Siguen pensando que somos distintos de los protozoos?
¿Que somos especiales?
En realidad, es peor incluso.
(Risas)
No estamos en la calle.
No, en serio. Si hay una diferencia entre nosotros y los protozoos,
una diferencia importante,
no solo el arte, la ciencia y la tecnología y demás,
es que podemos chillar y gritar, podemos salir a la calle
y con el tiempo cambiar la sociedad,
pero no lo hacemos.
Los magos llevan décadas argumentando
que la energía nuclear es clave para resolver el cambio climático.
Pero la primera manifestación pronuclear sucedió hace menos de dos años,
y fue eclipsada por las marchas antinucleares del pasado.
Los profetas llevan diciendo, literalmente, durante décadas,
que la conservación es clave para tener agua potable
sin destruir los ecosistemas que generan esas fuentes de agua potable.
Pero en la historia de la humanidad nunca ha habido una calle
llena de manifestantes con pancartas para protestar por tuberías dañadas.
De hecho, gran parte de la actividad política en esta esfera
ha sido la confrontación entre magos y profetas,
en vez de reconocer que están, en gran medida, del mismo lado.
Después de todo, a todos les preocupa lo mismo:
¿cómo nos las vamos a arreglar en un mundo de 10 mil millones?
El primer paso para generar ese movimiento social necesario,
para crear esa masa crítica y hacer que empecemos a chillar y a gritar,
parece obvio: los magos y los profetas deben unirse.
Pero ¿cómo se puede lograr eso dadas las décadas de hostilidad?
Una forma puede ser:
cada parte se compromete a aceptar las premisas fundamentales del otro.
Aceptar que la energía nuclear es segura y libre de carbono,
que las minas de uranio pueden ser terriblemente sucias
y que poner grandes cantidades de basura tóxica en trenes desvencijados
y hacerlos circular por todo el país es una idea malísima.
Para mí, esto lleva con bastante rapidez a una visión de pequeña escala,
a nivel barrial, con armas nucleares temporales,
y la energía nuclear como un puente mientras desarrollamos las renovables.
O aceptar que los cultivos modificados genéticamente son seguros
y que la agricultura industrial ha causado grandes problemas medioambientales.
Para mí, esto lleva con bastante rapidez a una visión de botánicos
que dedican mucha más atención a los cultivos arbóreos y de tubérculos,
que pueden ser mucho más productivos que los cereales,
consumen menos agua que los cereales y causan menos erosión.
Estas son solo ideas de un periodista cualquiera.
Estoy seguro de que hay muchas más y mejores en esta sala.
Lo importante es
que si los magos y los profetas trabajan juntos, pueden tener éxito.
Y tener éxito significaría mucho más que la simple supervivencia,
que no es poco.
Si la humanidad de alguna forma sobrevive a su propio brote,
si conseguimos comida y agua para todos, energía para todos,
si evitamos los peores efectos del cambio climático,
si de alguna manera podemos conservar el bioma,
sería increíble.
Creo que significaría, incluso para un cínico empedernido como yo,
que quizás sí seamos especiales.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)